I saw you took a trip to the Tesla
Factory what were your thoughts after
meeting Elon Musk did he get to speak to
him much I wouldn't say much we we spoke
probably for 20 minutes in total not
purely privately because there's other
people around but that just barely gets
you to know the surface of someone like
musk because he's an amazing person and
God only knows what's up with him all
things considered you know what do you
say about someone who built a functional
electric car then shot it into space on
a rocket he's a singular person the
Enterprise he's put together is
unbelievably high functioning to produce
an automobile sub-industry that's
actually competitive and to bring down
the cost of space exploration by a
factor of 10 and to invent reusable
rockets and to have developed this
boring technology there's only two
American car companies I think that
haven't gone bust forward in Tesla and
Tesla came very close a number of times
yeah it's an amazing accomplishment so
go Elon as far as I'm concerned yeah
he's a remarkable person hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because in my first business I struggled
to stay afloat I quit in my base
business partner and the thing that kept
me going was studying the stories of
famous entrepreneurs and seeing how they
struggled and seeing what they had to
overcome and listen to their wisdom
motivation gave me the Courage the
strength the belief to go one more day
and see my business through and in all
honesty I still need the inspiration
wisdom motivation today for my business
too so today let's live your best
believe life and learn what successful
people think about Elon Musk
do you have any advice for Elon Musk
um you as he buys Twitter of what he
should do on this
well
you know he actually could make it worse
uh that's not his track record I mean
his track record with tests on SpaceX is
pretty mind-blowing at putting together
a great team of Engineers and you know
taking the
people who worked in not those fields in
a less bold way and really showing them
up I I kind of doubt that'll happen this
time but we should have an open mind and
never underestimate Elon uh
you know what's his goal where he talks
about the openness
um you know how does he feel about
something that says vaccines kill people
or you know that Bill Gates is tracking
people is that one of the things he
thinks should be spread so it's still
it's not totally clear what he's going
to do talking of crazy stuff he's
tweeted about you recently a little bit
I mean how do you that doesn't bother me
and and are you shorting Tesla I mean
that's his sort of underlying concern
it's possible that the stock went down
and whoever shorted the stock made money
I don't know uh
is you know a statement about your
seriousness about climate change I'm
putting billions of dollars into climate
change Innovation I applaud Tesla's role
uh in helping with climate change uh and
you know I have nothing but positive
things to say about Elon
um if he met if he makes Twitter works
fine I'll I'll speak out about that but
I I wouldn't assume that okay what's
going to happen Tesla's now worth more
than GM and Ford do you have comments on
Elon Musk well you have to give him
credit I spoke to him very recently and
he's also doing the Rockets he likes
rockets and uh he does good at Rockets
too by the way I never saw where the
engines come down with no wings no
anything in their Landing I said I've
never seen that before
and I was worried about him because he's
one of our great Geniuses and we have to
protect our genius you know we have to
protect Thomas Edison and we have to
protect all of these people that came up
with originally the light bulb and the
wheel and all of these things and he's
one of our very smart people and we want
to we want to cherish those people
that's very important but he's done a
very good job uh shocking how well you
know how it's come so fast I mean you go
back a year
and they were talking about the end of
the company and now all of a sudden
they're talking about these great things
he's going to be building a very big
plant in the United States he has to
because we help him so he has to help us
Elon and his team are extraordinary what
they achieved and it um they all did
just fantastic
um competition is exactly right all I
can say is watch this space and we will
be coming uh with we're coming hopefully
out with a something very exciting over
the next very few months when do you
think you'll be in space when do you I
know you want to so bad
um virgin Virgin Galactic if it's not in
space in the next few months it would be
very disappointed and if it's not in
space with people in the HP months we'd
be very disappointed and and I hope I
hope that Virgin Galactic will be the
first of the sort of three uh the three
entrepreneurs that are fighting to get
put people into space the first the
first to get there and and that's that's
how that's our aim but you know we we've
got 800 Engineers working diligently to
make sure it's you know it's safe and
and we'll wait wait for their word
before we put anybody up do you even
know Elon Musk I've never I've never
said anything negative about England I
mean you're debating me a little bit to
do it but I am but uh but I've never you
know people like his car and everything
but uh
uh but somebody mentioned that now he's
talking about financing uh something
this morning about that I I I I thought
I heard that earlier yes it will
actually Andrew just read some headlines
where it looked like they may be Tesla
maybe going back to Market to to pick up
some additional financing I'm not
entirely sure all I hear was that all I
heard was the headline that's what I
call a counter Revelation I mean Charlie
you know because I think it was just a
few days ago they said they wouldn't
need financing
but you know he's trying something to
improve a product and I I salute him for
that also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there what do you think about Tesla
um is that company going to become a
major player
well
it's already created more significance
than anybody would have predicted
and
its founder is bold and brilliant
and swings for the fences
and of course people like that get some
remarkable results and sometimes they
get some quick failure
and I have the faintest idea how Elon
Musk is going to turn out but I think
he's got a considerable chance of
success in a considerable chance of
failure
he seems to like it that way
have you considered overnight Elon Musk
getting into the candy businesses he
suggested he might do on Twitter I
didn't hear that it sounds like wise
after he
I can't criticize anybody else for wise
answering what do you think is going to
happen Kevin O'Leary
you know I think what's lost in the
narrative particularly around detailing
illegals what's going to work who's
going to sue who is why is he doing this
in the first place and I think there's a
good reason
um Tesla and SpaceX and all of his other
initiatives pay zero dollars in
advertising nothing the only car company
on Earth that size that pays nothing in
advertising how did he do it he did it
on the back of Twitter and other social
media platforms very few people get to
own their own unregulated network which
is what Twitter is so you know borrowing
the price which obviously is overpaying
for he has a hundred million plus
followers now but he had 100 million
plus followers whether he owned the
asset or not but he doesn't control the
narrative there he doesn't control the
platform and frankly it is you know Iger
himself said we didn't buy this at
Disney because it's just loaded with
Bots and it's the slowest growing
platform it's the worst managed it's a
terrible company I I'm sorry to say that
but I use the platform too and I look at
all the metrics on versus all the other
ones including Tick Tock and Linkedin
and Instagram and Facebook it's the
worst in terms of getting your message
out now if he gets control of this thing
at whatever price and fixes it and
allows it to be a true narrative where
every voice is heard because I don't
like this canceling this politician
canceling that politician then it's a
world platform and I think this guy is
you know Teflon man and he can obviously
multitask I'd bet on him on this deal by
the time all this stuff is over I think
he's going to have a good outcome what
do you think Elon hero or villain the
internet's pretty split halfway at the
moment the idea that like he could
figure out spaceships and not Twitter
like Twitter isn't like a hard thing
like have you ever met someone in Tech
like they're not the best like
socializing human beings do you know
what I mean like it the fact that they
could figure out socializing like have
you seen them talk to each other like
Zuckerberg has to like be reminded to
Blink right like his eyes dry out he's
like oh I like MMA I like surfing blink
okay there you go right it's like so so
it's like there's there's these aren't
the people that are good at socializing
and they figured out apps around
socializing
Elon can figure out how to just write
something and post it it's not that
difficult so if I have no question he's
going to figure out it's going to be
better they'll have a billion users
they'll find out a way to monetize it
it'll be easy I think if you're a
billionaire you need in some sort of
like news apparatus to protect yourself
like there's a reason why Microsoft Bill
Gates got MSNBC the MS is Microsoft NBC
right Amazon got the Washington Post
it's like once you get enough money
where people should kill you because you
have that much money you need a
newspaper or something to be like yo
don't kill that guy you know what I'm
saying like that's what all the articles
are it's like you know Amazon gives 100
million dollars to this and it's just
like yo don't kill me is there another
difference between something that's
editorial and something that's just a
platform though like Bezos can influence
what goes out on the Washington Post a
lot more easily than Elon can tell
people what to tweet yeah but Elon can
also tweet whatever the [ __ ] he wants
and he can also never get removed not
not only can it never get removed but he
can also remove it said about him that's
fake
right he could be like that's fake news
he can't do that from The Washington
Post I'm not saying he would do this but
he can there's power yes you know you
and all news is on Twitter right now
that's what Twitter is it's really a
news feed right so the Washington Post
nobody goes to the Washington Post to
read an article they see the article pop
up on Twitter and then they go to it so
if they're posting fake news about Elon
he could be yeah that's fake news adios
see you later Elon Musk just said that
they sold their three millionth car
right about a month ago do you think
anyone can catch the Tesla and musk
right now or are they sort of in the
driver's seat when it comes to you well
the thing you have to realize about Elon
which is very clever
he came to this Garage in 2007 with his
prototype the Roadster it and that in
that early one that had a two-speed
transmission and a couple other things
right and
I remember sitting and he's telling me
about he said well what I want to do is
build charging stations all up and down
the coast and I'm going okay that'll
happen you're like oh that sounds good
but you know he started building the
infrastructure
almost at the exact time time he started
building the car so when the car debuted
you could drive LA to San Francisco and
now you can go anywhere in the country I
mean you see a lot of other automakers
get in the EV Market oh you can charge
it anywhere no you can't really you
might but it's 110 you're going to be
here 18 hours and you know so I I think
he should get a certain amount of credit
for leading the charge because before
Elon oh it's a golf cart people would
joke about electricity oh they're slow
then whatever it might be so I I give
him a lot of credit for it I mean I
think the EV will be the savior of the
classic car industry
not such a big Elon Musk fan
but it is Elon musk's it's rough but let
me tell you any great leader is rough
any great leader has a strong opinion
and isn't so smooth on the edges and
drives it home but that's what you want
when you want to reinvent a category and
that's what he's done you have to hand
it to the guy and he's good looking I
think I gotta ask you about Elon Musk
you know that's the question who's Elon
Musk oh he's this guy that's got a few
bucks Twitter what a great investment
that was yes do you think I was going to
ask you do you think that was a really
good investment investing in Twitter I
do I do we all follow Twitter yeah I
mean it's gonna do a great job with the
platform yeah it's a genius how do you
think this is going to affect
shareholders for Tesla
I think they're overthinking about it I
think they just leverage part of the
loan but I think it's going to be fine
do you think there'll be any issue with
it going through because that's the talk
right now with the Tesla shows sliding
in value that it might not close now now
I think he's got a liquidity on carry it
through do you think there's any legal
implications that are going to happen
based on what he's been tweeting thank
you so much
really who's going to shut up Elon Musk
right right I didn't say anything how
much how much of an influence you think
this is going to have on the election
uh you know we have midterms coming up
in November I think this is going to
have any effect on that I think it's
going to be really tough I mean you know
what was it uh piso's bought the New
York Times
post the post right I mean musk is
buying the biggest newspaper platform in
the world why all right what a voice
will have I think you have a great
influence forever what do you think is
going to be the biggest impact of Elon
buying Twitter
uh influence in the media in America and
globally
so this right here is why Elon Musk is a
genius if you don't know Twitter blue is
your premium service it costs eight
dollars a month to be able to use but
elon's also been in a massive fight with
apple uh CEO Tim Cook over their feast
like he thinks it's ridiculous that
people have to pay 30 uh fee to Apple
for anything sold through the Apple
Store and people have been pissed for
years about this and nobody has done
anything about it except for just a
little bit of complaining Elon joked
about being able to build his own phone
company to rival apple he also talked
about maybe getting kicked out of the
Apple store which wouldn't be good for
Twitter or Elon because now he loses a
big user base and it's also not great
for Apple because they're already being
watched by the Monopoly Watch Dogs so
that doesn't help that they have so much
power so this right here is an amazing
Solutions like hey you're charging me
more I'm gonna pass that on to the users
where it's eight dollars if you buy to
the web or eleven dollars if you buy
through the App Store he's Shifting the
blame to Apple
we haven't already gone completely head
to head so far so Elon is interested in
sending people to Mars
um we are more interested in our Earth
that we live on like connecting the four
billion people are not connected here on
Earth or giving people the chance to go
to space who are here on Earth we will
overlap and he will be a formidable
competitor but you know like in most
businesses there's definitely room for
the two of us there'll be there's room
for Jeff Bezos and I think in time that
they run for others as well all the
market research we've shown the demand
from people who want to go into space is
infinite we just got to make sure that
they can have a very safe ride and and
an affordable ride and that's the
challenge that Virgin Galactic has set
itself what do you make of Elon Musk
you've spoken about him a bit you might
have struck with admiration
that's what I mean I always think of
that as a primary well it's all it's
like do you find this comedian funny
it's like well I laugh at him
you know what I mean it's not
propositional again
and so
I would there are things I would like to
ask Mr musk about
the Mars Venture I don't know what he's
up to there it strikes me as absurd in
the most fundamental sense because I
think while it'd be easier just to build
an outpost in the Antarctica or in the
desert well how much of the human
endeavor is absurd well that's what it
needs to say great men are seldom
credited with their stupidity who the
hell knows what musk is up to I mean
obviously he's building Rockets now he's
motivated because he wants to build a a
platform for Life on Mars is that a good
idea
who am I to say dude he's he's building
the Rockets man but I'd like to ask him
about it I I would like to see that
conversation I do think that having
talked to him quite a bit offline I
think these
several of his ideas like Mars like he
was becoming a multi-pilotary species
could be one of the things that human
civilization looks back at as
duh I can't believe he is one of the few
people that was really pushing this idea
because it's the obvious thing for for
Society for life to survive yeah well it
isn't obvious to me that I'm in any
position to evaluate Elon Musk like I
would like to talk to and find out what
he's up to and why but I mean he's an
impossible person what he's done is
impossible all of it
it's like he built an electric car that
works now does it work completely and
will it replace gas cars or should it I
don't know but if we're going to build
electric cars He seems to be the best at
that buy a lot and he more or less did
that people carp about him but he more
or less did that by himself I know he's
very good at Distributing responsibility
and all of that but he's the spearhead
and then that was pretty hard and then
he built a rocket
at like one tenth the price of NASA
rockets and then he shot his car out
into space
that's pretty hard and then he's
building this boring company more or
less as a what would you call it it's
sort of it's this Whimsical joke in some
sense but it's not a joke he's amazing
and you're a link delving into the uh
the depths of the mind and starlink it's
like go Elon as far as I'm concerned
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome this is
the top 50 I did on Elon Musk check the
video right on next to me I think you'll
love it
you do believe and I'll see you there
when my brother and I were starting our
first company instead of getting an
apartment we just rented a small office
and we slept on the couch
and we showered at the YMCA and